[Music]
uh
how are you ross hello tom fancy
here well we were going to talk about
our favorite
scene or sequence which is kind of it's
kind of hard to be asked to picture
special mentions i definitely love
one of my favorite sequences just as a
special mention is when robin is talking
to the hat
and pretending that the hat is her dad
because it's just pure animation and
it's just pure acting and everything
that's really nice
don't mind if i do last hard day hunting
ah not a sniff of wolf out there
well what if i told you i can get all
the wolves to leave
and we don't even have to kill them i'd
say you're telling tortillas again
oh but i'm not now promise me you won't
get angry
i promise you see i met a girl in the
forest who has
magic healing powers she healed merlin
and she's a wolf walker and then when
when robin and maeve have that little
breakup scene when they go into the
scullery and
we tried out some nice framing uh
compositional
um choices there and also it really tugs
on their heart strings too
you have to listen to me you must leave
the forest take the walls and go
but you said you'd help me i'm helping
you
the only way i can you promised the lord
protectable birth in the woods he will
kill all the wolves by sunset
you have to get them out do you
understand
now go like this beautiful animation of
maeve when
you almost hear her heart breaking and
even even robin when robin turns towards
us but she has her back to maeve
i think it was emmanuel manuel and
matild and they did some beautiful stuff
in there
it's kind of hard to pick one because so
many people did so much beautiful work
across
the whole movie but i don't know i think
for me it's yeah
some scenes are some scenes are like um
are like a favorite maybe because of an
emotional beat or a tone or a mood and
some are
like maybe with an introduction of a
character but i think um
i think from everything that we've been
talking about over the last couple of
months
uh the running with the world sequence
is it takes
quite a bit i think for me as well
because it kind of
is the visual and musical high
point as well as the emotional high
point of the movie and you can hear
every little thing something moves
[Music]
and your paws can hear through the earth
the fact that like um when robin and
maeve met as as little girls
it was such a special moment and we were
looking to try and find a place for that
same beautiful kind of getting to know
each other
and form and we couldn't do it as with
them as little girls in the plot that we
had you know they were
constantly being separated so we just
had to take advantage of the fact that
this was their last
moment to really have a nice time
together and
and continue that friendship before the
inevitable
spliff
[Music]
this is going to be the most difficult
sequence in the movie because it had
everything
like four-legged animals yeah wolf
fishing and
packs of wolves running around and and
then like also even the effects like
moving trees in the wind and thunder and
lightning and
splashing through water and everything
so yeah we knew that it was
that it was going to be a a big task
from every department but um
but it had to be worth it you know it
had to be like as you say the high point
so many people work on just like a few
seconds of what ends up on screen
and you might have your superstar
animator doing the characters but no
less superstars are all the support team
and you know the
artists that work all around it so just
to get a few seconds of that
technique on screen was a lot of work
we're really lucky that the pipeline
like ran really smoothly
i remember hearing that aurora song um
and running along as i was listening to
it and i wouldn't say like i pictured
the
whole sequence but i definitely got a
feeling that it was going to be
uh a tent pole and i i knew i had my
work cut out for me convincing everybody
that we should use
that particular song but i felt
something like this at least
would work there yeah you i remember you
you were so excited when you came back
from that run you were like you gotta
listen to this you gotta listen to this
song
and lyrically it was perfect and and
also like the
the feeling of aurora's voice too the
tone of it was was
uh perfect too
[Music]
there is
definitely for me anyway it's a high
point in my career when i look at that
sequence i feel like wow
you just feel so tiny and kind of lucky
to be
the cheerleader or the conductor of an
amazing orchestra at that point because
it's way more than anything i could ever
have imagined on that original
run in the castle park go us
go team well done
[Music]
tonight